walk him to this video penguin penguin
yes from the US and playing c4 for a
change English opening let's see what
he's doing the reversed dragon with d5
and now is playing the carillon which I
recently played named after power carers
the legendary Grandmaster kromom from
Estonia blood okay so default device the
most principled move nowadays neither
three he can play a form and down that's
not so sure so convincing yeah this is
one possibility also there's the caption
Queen takes g5 this is actually how I
played in a recent game here on the
assessee I played d6 now which looks
very logical to keep the center me
taking now with the bishop exchange does
not make so much sense maybe if maybe
you can play if all this looks very
ambitious though it probably makes yeah
yeah I'm not saying that it is bad but
its ambitious p.m. maybe I could I can
play even this more from i'm going to
try that try to isolate in a way this
pawn trying to round it up and to win it
with 93 maybe night h3g 5 take it the
hotel atif was just 93 of course but
then he can play d5 and protect
porn yeah would have been normal though
I'm fire head on the clock snotty is not
exactly quick okay to play 93-95 now i
mean i can't play em I can play before I
don't see why I shouldn't Oh interesting
me yeah the question may be it may be
taking with the night even maybe yeah
that's that's actually the most the most
direct way to play so now i can take and
take you four get to get the pawn yeah
i'm gonna i'm doing that i don't really
seem see anything else the point is also
why i need to do this I need to get rid
of the pawn on e4 simply to to to get
Knight f3 in the game yeah why won't you
go back or to g5 back that gets back is
slow but probably
yeah he has some development that's
that's clear there is the idea queen bee
to at the moment queen bee to queen bee
293 check quite awkward and however and
then i will get quite substantial lead
in development but else I quadruped you
one maybe rooty one detecting them d 3
square
yeah i would consider d5 here on for
black trying to to to really blast open
the position and tending Bishop f5
threatening 93 yeah here I think I can
play Queen d4 actually I think I'm out
of the woods now yeah it's a nap in now
yeah night 2 h 2 f for what
rookie to checkmate are you serious wow
Bishop c6 rookie to made John Wow but
the night f4 here he will take g2 can
you believe that amazing okay I need to
take it the good thing is it's it's
still ok for me I believe with Queen d5
but this is sheer luck yeah that's
that's so good actually what a shot
tonight takes g3 am really shocked I'm
really shocked here ok take with the
rook b6 still let's better from a
structural point of view six points I I
am I don't I don't even have a porn I
don't have an extra porn it's
unbelievable ok may takes chi 3 just wow
yeah I mean it's still a bit a bit of an
edge because of the better bone
structure I don't know that is well
developed I only have to pawn Island see
Scott three this that is that is
something came Knight c3 now kept that
it's a good square I don't want to
return them game
yeah still many weaknesses for black
petisco this bishop I cannot go to the
one I cannot go to h1 grawr Arthur I
don't know but it's still it's still
somewhat better sorry I can we use this
route and go from there but how do I get
get somewhere probably need to regroup
shrine with the rook to a forum and try
to yeah but this does not really need
too much time warning no not sure how to
make progress
okay maybe maybe with a four a five this
is a possibility ok now a five yeah now
I know I have a six year as a as a nice
target okay my deaf for I have beautiful
I've actually taking okay seven very
important black forfeits on time yeah
despite this fantastic shot I think
white still had Ted something because of
the pawn structure and I takes three
three holy holy moly Wow so I need to do
something else here I mean if i don't
fall to this shot and i'm probably just
winning yeah the computer grease with
that it says III and 92 wins it's a here
I actually keep the pawn and here 93 m
great check me what a nice checkmate
yeah and the fun thing is if i go here
yeah like covering this covering this he
just takes him it's this nice it's again
a checkmate great just great so this is
the only way to proceed yeah yeah white
enjoys a little something because of the
structure black guy probably should not
lose but it's tricky tricky to play what
I don't like really is this g5 move this
creates creates even more weaknesses and
it does not really have any a
substantial benefit
and one I wondered about d5 here
actually but I can take and play books
you want yeah with Luke c7 kill me
that's pretty good for white yeah now I
get it into play it's still not it's
still not so self-evident how what is
really winning this the bishop on f3 is
just immensely strong yeah I don't see a
clear-cut plan to improve the position
he played this a 6 + f5 and this gave me
some some ideas here this is actually
winning but it wasn't really a force
term a fast way to play here he helped
me a bit here Wow but this is like III
still still amazes me a great move
really alright thanks for watching